good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video comes to you in two parts part 1 I
have a dream as I was watching all the
Olympic athletes walk into the stadium
during the opening ceremonies you know
what I was thinking I was thinking that
should be me that's right Hank I'm a 34
year old man according to my BMI am 1.6
pounds overweight and I want to be an
Olympian now I know you're saying Hank
walking on a treadmill desk does not
qualify me to be an Olympian and in fact
you're probably saying John you're too
old for the Olympics well no I'm not and
Kuroshio hick ETSU a Japanese horse
riding person is 71 years old and he's
in the Olympics admittedly first
qualified for the Olympics in 1964 and I
don't know how to ride a horse but still
it's possible but then you might say
John you can't be in the Olympics you're
a nerdfighter nerds aren't Olympians oh
yes they are
Hank there's at least one known Olympian
nerdfighter Jennifer pinches a gymnast
representing Great Britain who just did
the nerdfighter sign in front of the
world after an awesome floor exercise
dftba jennifer i would show you the
footage of this momentous occasion but
unfortunately the ioc would then come to
my house and steal my baby that's the
rule if you violate their copyright they
take your baby now lastly hank you're
probably saying well both hiroshi huh
katsu and jennifer Pinchas are good at
something athletic and you're not and
never have been fair enough
so obviously I'm gonna have to be an
Olympian for a team sport because I'm
gonna be the worst player on the team
what sport men's team handball which
happens to be the only big Olympic sport
at which the US doesn't feel the team
now Hank obviously I'm never gonna build
a men's team handball team good enough
to win a medal there are a lot of good
handball teams out there but I don't
have to all I have to do is build a
men's Olympic handball team that's good
enough to qualify for the Olympics so I
figure I get some passionate washed-up
basketball players I get them all
treadmill desks we get to working out
all the time we get the big muscles and
throw in the hand balls and we just
qualify then they make a movie about us
it'd be like Cool Runnings meets
dodgeball already at the Hollywood pitch
line all I'm lacking really is like the
teammates and the motivation and the
understanding of how you qualify for the
Olympics this is probably never going to
happen but I do want to congratulate
Jennifer Pinchas on being awesome and
living her dream I'm so proud of
Jennifer Pichet sorry I jumped up and
down on my treadmill desk I'm so so
proud by the way everyone do I have
these binoculars it's because there's a
strange semi aquatic mammal that
periodically appears outside my office
window
I think it's possibly some kind of
secret agent but anyway I'm trying to
identify whether he's an otter or a
muskrat
part two hank friday is esther day the
most important holiday in nerdfighteria
it's the day that we honor our friend
Esther who inspired so much of The Fault
in Our Stars and inspires so much of
nerdfighteria and we honor her by
telling the people in our life whom we
love that we love them this year
Esther's family is having an awesome
Esther day event in Quincy Massachusetts
there's a link in the doobly-doo to find
out more you should totally go they're
going to be a ton of nerdfighters there
and you can also be part of a t-shirt
design contest for this star won't go
out the organization that Esther's
family set up in her memory you can
learn more about that in the doobly-doo
Hank I just love Esther day and I'm so
grateful to Esther for giving us the
gift of making us say to each other I
love you I'll see you on Friday